oh my goodness
date night action here in sin city how
you feeling
good it's uh i've kind of taken it easy
this trip for the most part so i'm
feeling pretty good and you know excited
to be here big night for for country
music
so yeah excited to be a part of it mom
and dad's night out i know it's fun
we're excited to be here we're gonna get
dressed up yeah what's up no go go
i really have nothing to say it's fun
well i'm gonna make it suck chase you
have three nominations tonight sharing
with carrie underwood how great has it
been to work so closely with her it's
been great i mean this song has been uh
you know a big song obviously for us all
year and
um
you know it's just i had the idea for
this song and to bring her in on it and
it's it's nice when you have a plan and
it works out you know so uh it's been a
huge song
this year got nominated for you know
three awards here and and uh even a
grammy for that excuse me for that song
so
it's it's been a big one and she's been
great
we've had a chance to perform it now a
few times together and and it's uh it's
always fun you know her son jacob is
three years old navy is three years old
i know you guys see where i'm going with
this i do could they be the next country
couple i mean i'm not opposed or is navy
never allowed to date that's that's
probably accurate yeah that's probably
actually i feel like she does what she
wants i don't feel like you're getting
yeah i don't know if i'm gonna have much
say in that but uh yeah we'll see she's
pretty strong headed you know what i
mean when the time comes who's going to
be the more protective parent when it
comes to dating for both of the babies
oh no i feel like i
mean i feel like she's going to be more
protective of our son yes and then i'll
probably be more protective of navy so
uh but yeah
who's this chick that's coming home
oh i'm not gonna it's gonna be very hard
for me
no jason you are no stranger to sin city
you did a limited residency not too long
ago could that be something more
permanent in the future maybe you know i
think uh i think that's something that i
you know would entertain a little bit
down the road
i still enjoy
going out on the road and traveling and
getting on the bus and hanging out with
my guys i still enjoy that too much to
to postpone it and kind of just play
here but uh you know i think at some
point
down the road it's something i'd be open
to and and we'll just kind of see how it
goes i like coming in you know once or
twice a year right now and sort of just
having some fun for a few days you know
now in the meantime the second half of
your 10th studio album 10 of them is
coming out soon in april what does this
music mean to you
uh well first of all just it's it's
crazy that i've
been allowed to make 10 records over the
years you know and and that i'm still
you know out there and can still put out
songs that people
seem to still react to we get to come be
a part of these things and
it's just it's a big honor for me just
to still kind of be around
and uh a lot of times i feel like i'm
still the new kid on the block which i
know i'm not but um but it's uh it's
been great you know it's been fun and
just a testament to
you know our songs and albums that we
put out over the years the fans how well
they supported us and it's been great
it's been very well deserved
congratulations on everything always so
lovely to see you